all right joining us now with reaction
all of this author of unfreedom of the
press which is coming out very soon he
holds life liberty and Levin right here
on the Fox News Channel host of Levin TV
nationally syndicated radio I call him
the great one Mark Levin mark you used
to be the you work for ed Meese you're
as chief of staff okay we you talked at
length about long-standing policy about
in dining a sitting president bar said
it had nothing to do with it Boris ed
Muller had no consideration to do with
it right so call me who we now know the
FBI was informed fully about the dirty
dossier he signed the first FISA warrant
to me he's the one in legal jeopardy
ironically and not the president all
right what ought to happen here is there
ought to be a grand jury impaneled Comey
should give testimony mccabe should get
testimony Baker should give testimony
stroke page the whole cabal should be
giving testimony they should get a
little bit of their own medicine should
have a criminal grand jury and we should
have either a special counsel or a
United States attorney take charge of
this case and get to the bottom of it
put these people under oath and let them
get the donald trump treatment we want
all their documents no privileges
nothing drag him in and maybe drag their
kids into but i wanted to talk about
something else because nancy pelosi's
quite ubiquitous these days she's barely
coherent she is a constitutional
illiterate but that's the person they
chose his speaker of the house and i got
to thinking she's very very rich she's a
multimillionaire
i don't really care about that she has a
husband people don't even know his name
is paul pelosi he's a san francisco risk
real estate developer he's a financial
investor tell me how did the Pelosi's
make their money tell me who do they
know are there any foreign interests we
seen their bank accounts and we've seen
their tax returns I'm curious because
Nancy Pelosi like Eva Peron today she
announced that we make the laws in the
House of Representatives and I need to
remind the speaker the house actually
you don't you pass bills and they're not
laws until they go through the Senate
and the president signs of that's how
the system works
but I'd like to know about all their
connections how they got so rich I
really would
what we have here is an attack when the
President had attack on his family
collusion special counsel contempt
obstruction constitutional crisis I just
started writing them down
impeachment tax returns bank accounts
they want they've already leaked some of
his tax information they accuse them of
campaign violations they accuse them
being a racist and anti-semite mentally
unfit for office let me tell you what's
going on here the Democrat Party has
hijacked the House of Representatives
this is an opposition research the
campaign they're working for whomever
the Democrat nominee is if they can
impeach the president don't impeach the
president what they're trying to do is
drive down his ratings to get them under
30% and then they'll go for impeachment
otherwise they'll act like he should be
impeached they'll talk about a
constitutional crisis these are the
talking points now they create the
conflicts they create the issues they
create the confrontation the issue
scores and scores of subpoenas six
committees the Committee Chairman as I
speak our meeting and dark in some
shadowy room trying to figure out how to
bring down the president the United
States how to embarrass him to go after
his businesses they go after his son
they go after his associates they go
after his council they go after him
what is the purpose of all this oh well
we want to know if the IRS is working
let me tell you secret the IRS isn't
working it never works so that's not an
issue well we want to make sure there
isn't any foreign collusion great then
all you members of the House and Senate
you cough up your tax returns in your
bank accounts so we can make sure you're
not in the back pocket of some of some
third world country well we just want to
make sure our financial system works
well let me tell you something that
works you don't work the debt is through
the roof everybody can see through this
and it's not just the federal Democrats
Maryland and DC the Democrats get
together there they bring a phony
lawsuit the emoluments Clause because
the president has a hotel and foreigners
stay there so he must be making money on
the side such BS
New York state tax returns
gonna pass a bill of attainder which is
federally unconstitutional what is that
a law aimed at one citizen the president
we're gonna turn his state tax returns
over to Congress let me tell you what's
going on this is a Democrat Party cabal
trying to reverse the 2016 election
trying to disenfranchise 63 million
voters mostly Republicans independents
that some Democrats led by a speaker of
the house from San Francisco a chairman
of the House Judiciary Committee from
New York the chairman of the Oversight
Committee from Baltimore three or four
blue cities trying to change the course
of this country trying to reverse the
course of the election and let me tell
you they keep saying the American people
want they don't represent the American
people they keep saying they're
following the Constitution they're
shredding the Constitution they don't
even know what's in the Constitution it
is we who are standing up to this cabal
this rogue activity it is we who are
standing up for the Constitution and let
me tell you something work they are
playing with political fire there are
tens of millions of people who are not
going to stand for this and they are
gonna vote they're gonna become more
active than ever before and they are
going to not only lose the presidency
they will lose the house we will
strengthen the Senate and then maybe and
they maybe will subpoena the hell out of
them and then maybe we'll have special
counsels against them because if they
want to use Soviet tactics against
Republicans then the only way the
Democrats know to stop is if Soviet
tactics are used against them that's it
when's the book out the book comes out
May 21 people can pre-order it on
amazon.com or any of those sites and
somewhere that gets to it's a very very
important interview for that book we
have it arranged they're ready but will
will make the announcement at the
appropriate time great one that's why we
love you the great one congratulations
my friend Sunday nights 10:00 p.m. the
number one show on cable